[Music]
hello there you are watching The Press
preview first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
Daily Mirror con this Susie Boniface and
the daily telegraphs associate editor
for politics Christopher hope they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the poll
conducted by the eye suggests that 6 out
of ten voters would rather receive cash
handouts than Liz truss's preferred
strategy for easing the cost of living
crisis that being tax cuts
the times leads with Michael Gove
describing mistrust's tax plans as a
holiday from reality as he announces his
endorsement of her Tory leadership rival
Rishi sunak
the telegraph hears that in a repeat of
the strategy used at the height of covid
the NHS will warn people to stay away
from a e departments during the winter
unless they absolutely need them
the guardian quotes Liz trust saying the
NHS should not be put on a pedestal
the male criticizes the NHS for
allegedly being too woke
The Mirror Has word of Sir Alex
Ferguson's testimony for the defense at
the assault trial of his former player
Ryan Giggs who denies the charges
against him
that's also the main story for the star
the express cites a government report
suggesting the migrant crisis in the
channel could last for another five
years
PFD has a story concerning the U.S stock
market
the sun reports that the actor Stephen
Tomkinson known for his roles in DCI
Banks and balika's Angel has been
charged with Grievous bodily harm
following an incident in North tyneside
he's pleaded not guilty
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie bonface and Christopher hope
welcome to you both let's start with the
times and Michael goes endorsement of
Rishi sunaka and quite harsh criticism
of Liz truss it's come at the the ninth
hour there hasn't hit this endorsement
is it a little bit too late Christopher
well I think with around nearly
two-thirds of votes already cast
According to some polling
um it's a bit too I wonder whether the
Liz trust team won't mind too much
because for a lot of the brexiteers
Michael Gove is quite a toxic character
and here's a tackle on this trust won't
be much of a surprise he says in the
times page one here and this is a big
deal there's a political story of
tomorrow morning he says that the trust
campaign has been a whole day from
reality and it has been a sense of phony
war going on when you've got all sorts
of tax cuts flying about plans for
police plans for schools plans for
everything but not really enough to
tackle what men is seen as the major
issue the cost of living crisis that's
of worrying people along with what might
be a massive winter of discontent which
could bring the government very swiftly
to its knees there's a feeling right now
one of unreality with the Prime Minister
sitting on it sitting in checkers with
his Trotters up or in Green in Ireland
somewhere in the Mediterranean while big
issues are being faced here by families
with no real political leadership and
that's what jobs getting at in this
heart hitting piece also very
interestingly he's revealing his exit
from Frontline politics and the times
the times of course is where he used to
work he knows the Murdoch's very well
maybe he wants to get back to being a
senior person at the times again where
he was once but this is a this is um
maybe uh half a farewell from I think a
brilliant politician who who can get
things done in Whitehall when he wants
to I think the work he's done in
Whitehall over dealing with the issue of
cladding and taking on those developers
is what is hugely credited to him yes
and he claims to to be being you know
genuine he says he's making his case for
sunac from his heart because he believes
his front bench career is over whichever
candidate wins I do not expect to be in
government again but it was the
privilege of my life to spend 11 years
in the cabinet under three prime
ministers So speaking from the heart and
he genuinely believes that Rishi sunak
is a should be the the next the next
leader Susie
yeah and Gabe actually back to Camry
badnock early on in the race but of
course she fell out quite a long time
ago she dropped out so the fact that
he's taken this long to declare
um who he thinks should win implies that
perhaps it was a bit up in the air or
there was something else going on that
he was weighing things up in some way
um perhaps it wasn't a complete slam
dunk who knows maybe he's just busy
doing something else uh he's not quite
announcing his retirement from politics
he's just saying he doesn't expect to be
in a government of course he may be
pleasantly surprised by a future Prime
Minister having to drop a period or a
sardom or something else in his lap I
don't doubt he is quite nice about Liz
in this piece apart from her economic
plans which she calls this holiday from
reality and the fact that it's just
going to devastate businesses across
this country when the energy price cap
and the energy prices really kick in
because course businesses small
businesses and bigger business do not
have to do not get their energy capped
it's bad enough for the likes of us I
spent half of today arguing with my
provider because they randomly pushed up
my direct debit to an unreasonable
amount but at least my energy is capped
if you're running a small business it is
uncapped and as you your viewers have
seen there are businesses being given
seventy thousand pound bills that they
just can't pay and those businesses are
shutting down the fact that conservative
politicians
um don't see the massive economic damage
that is hanging just around the corner
and coming at all of us I find
absolutely astonishing and I find
further astonishing that you've got two
people who want to be prime minister who
are fighting for that and on who for
whom on day one the energy crisis is
going to be the number one issue on
their desk that they have to fix right
now
and we don't have them arguing about the
best way of doing it this trust just
says there's going to be an emergency
budget she doesn't say what she's going
to do Rishi um also is a little bit
vague about things although Chris will
know more about the detail than me but
that they're not putting their plan on
the table for exactly how they're going
to tackle this and the fact they're not
I think is a massive abdication of
public duty which is what gov is showing
in this column here he's showing that he
does have that sense of public duty
whether you agree with him or not and he
thinks Rishi does too he seems less
fulsome about Liz
um just quickly before we move on um
because do you agree with that that
analysis from from Susie there that
they're not tackling the cost of living
crisis uh urgently enough
it's been raising and you are seeing
some support from from Ricky like he
wants to Target those who need it most
uh this trust is going for more of a
wider tax cutting agenda uh don't forget
we're dealing with just 160 000 people
here many of whom are quite well off
these are Tory member members
um we are basically witnessing it all
but looking through the glass window
they're not talking to the rest of the
country we're talking to this group of
people who I think yes and there's no
question that and Susie is right on day
one of them being prime minister on
September the 6th that will be front and
center but until that point
um the party are trying to weigh out
whether this person is good at other
areas to transport defense
um Health everything else so I think to
be fair to them they are trying to
discuss many different areas they're not
really none of them are in power yet but
um really you know arguably you have got
the names of Harvey calling in
um energy bosses last week trying to get
them to talk about cost of living crisis
he's doing papers now try and present to
the next prime minister whoever that
might be so it's a it's a confused
picture on who's in charge frankly and
that's part of the problem the the eye
majoring on that Liz truss's uh tax
plans uh they suggest that they're not
popular with the the public they would
rather be given uh money than have uh
tax cuts uh be brought in
Susie
yeah well some people are saying wishes
to next team says that Liz trusses sort
of announcement of tax cuts we give some
families just a pound extra which of
course isn't gonna cut the mustard when
you get your energy bills
um and you know what they actually need
is help with the the debt they have now
not perhaps a reassessment of how much
comes out of their pay packet or they
get via their tax man you know it's a
few months hence that's just gonna be
too late
um and although it's very it's perfectly
Fair like for Chris to say you know the
two leadership candidates have got lots
of different issues they're arguing
about and then they're trying to lay out
their stool for it and all the rest of
it and in normal circumstances I'd say
well that's what they should be doing
but right now you know the next prime
minister whoever it is is not going to
have the time to talk about agricultural
subsidies or the relationship with EU or
uh you know what's going to happen with
Ukraine because on day one if you don't
fix the cost of living crisis and the
cost of energy somehow power or another
then you're not going to get today six
right the government is going to fall
very quickly if they don't get this
susque it's the biggest and the only
thing they should be talking about the
other stuff is a luxury well one other
thing that uh Liz truss certainly is
talking about uh Christopher is the NHS
which she doesn't believe should be put
on a pedestal that's in the garden
uh that's right I think that that goes
back to I mean this is a I was watching
the GB news uh hustings number nine of
12 today uh earlier before I came on air
I mean there's a huge Applause when
um the the leaders the Chinese they're
asked will you not put the NHS in a
pedestal pedestal will you deal with
weights in NHS these are things which um
the toys have been thinking about going
back into the into the mid-naughties I
think Liz truss is showing her the
reason why she's a front runner she's
not willing she's um forgive me she's
um not gonna put things on her pedestal
she will take on areas where the left
think are sacrosanct and I think that
makes it quite popular amongst the
Grassroots well that's why even the
gardeners saying that won't do any harm
at all
okay thank you both for the moment uh
Christopher and Susie we're going to
take a break coming up the Finnish prime
minister agrees to take a drugs test
after being filmed dancing at a party
but is there a double standard at work
in terms of her gender we'll discuss
that next
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview still
with me Susie Boniface and Christopher
hope let's take a look at the
telegrapher from Paige um and Susie take
us into this story the NHS telling
people to stay away from a e
um ahead of the the winter why
they're planning sort of a bit of a
publicity Blitz to say look we're going
to be under a lot of strain this winter
please don't you know please help us to
help you sort of thing but it's pointed
out by medics in there and I think
anybody who's had to go to hospital
whether it's a false alarm or not would
probably find that this Rings true that
the correct person to make a decision
about whether or not you need medical
treatment is the is the doctor is the
medic is the person who's doing the
triage when you get into hospital so if
you are the kind of person who's going
to go to hospital for something you
don't need to go to hospital for the
fact that the hospital says is an
emergency make sure you want to think
about it actually you're not going to
stay away You're Still Enough of an
idiot to go to hospital because you've
got an ingrown toenail however if you're
the kind of person who goes oh wouldn't
know is this rash is this something I
need to worry about I best stay away
from hospital actually you're the one
the doctor does want to see because it
can theoretically be something appalling
and awful and they want you to go to
hospital they want to see you and they
really want to tell you it's nothing too
serious I had to go to a e um a little
while ago with my six-year-old who had
suspected appendicitis we went through a
whole rigmarole of different doctors and
everything else it turned out to be just
a bug but every single doctor we saw
said no you did the right thing bringing
her in you did the right thing it could
have been serious we have to see her we
want to tell what the problem is and so
the Medics are saying this whole
business of keeping people away to save
the NHS actually it keeps away the
people we need to see it doesn't stop
the time wasters and that there's better
ways of doing it a more effective system
of triage for the walking room didn't a
e would probably do a better job than
this kind of thing which we saw during
the covered lockdowns and of course
meant that a lot of people went without
the treatment they needed Christopher do
you think people are going to to stay
away
I agree with what Suzy said I think that
you know they they if you've got a
problem you should go to go to the
doctor this is good it's gonna you know
I mean coming in in the context of this
change of government we're going to see
in in less than two weeks time this is
an example of why many think NHS needs
to try and work out what it's doing
fewer managers more Frontline staff
there are ways around this
um there's a guy called Professor Tim
Briggs who has done some work on this to
show that you you can get it right first
time you know just can do better with
the money it's got
um less waste
um and I think it's almost it would be
frustrating for a lot of people in
government on the Tory side that this is
happening so early in the summer we're
nowhere near the winter crisis everyone
knows that flu is worse in Winter we're
still in August it's still hot outside
let us turn to the Ft Susie and the
Finnish prime minister's uh right to
party or fight to party even
quite that what happened here is that
the Finnish prime minister who's only in
her 30s and is very young and very
beautiful
um and has had a little bit of Scandal
previously for going out clubbing when
she should have been getting a covert
alert to stay at home
um has been the subject of what can only
really be described as an internet
campaign by far right trolls in Finland
because this video has come out it's
very brief they have claimed in this
video that they're talking about Cocaine
by using the word flour uh in Finnish
drug culture apparently I'm informed not
an expert on it but I'm told that that's
not a euphemism for cocaine at all in
Finland and it can't even really be
heard on the video and because of the
pressure because of the 4chan the
internet trolls who were pushed and
pushed and pushed this and people who
really don't like a woman and perhaps as
well some kind of connection from the
old Petersburg troll factories run by
Vladimir Putin because he's very upset
with Santa Marin and her attempts to get
Finland closer to Nato as a result of
his aggression in Ukraine
um that's kind of created a scandal
where there really wasn't one it's a
young woman dancing with some friends
when she didn't have anything else to do
and what's wrong with dancing you know
we've had Michael Gove dancing in a
nightclub looking off his face it was
just a bit of an amusement what we got
Boris Johnson doing goodness knows what
half the time with goodness knows whom
but and again it's not a big issue but
we're running we're running out of time
just very quickly Christopher's looking
perplexed very quickly Christopher
I was trying to say I mean come off it
Susie I mean he's a world leader here
who loves dancing around like a maniac
on on the screen here and she and people
are saying is she okay I thought you'd
volunteered to take a drug test I mean
why are you bringing in all sorts of um
conspiracy theories involving Russians I
mean surely it is not bringing it in
that's how the Scandal that's how the
story developed that's why it's the
story
but she must accept that given she's now
accepts to have a drug test to clear the
air I mean it's just a question of is it
appropriate for someone on the world
stage to behave like that in a dancing
video I think Michael Goldberg was
embarrassed by that dancing in in the in
the nightclub in in August uh two years
ago Christopher and Susie I'm afraid
we're gonna have to to leave leave it
there you'll have to pursue your debate
off air for the moment